la parole est à monsieur alain dufaut ce
groupe l'est républicain avait la parole
mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre la culture à l'occasion d'un
colloque au dernier festival de cannes
le 17 mai dernier le premier ministre a
estimé que la baisse du budget de la
culture
au cours des deux premières années du
gouvernement de françois hollande était
un signe négatif et votre prédécesseur
madame me serais dit philippe itil le
lendemain sur france info n'a pas manqué
de commenter cette réaction de manuel
valls en précisant je la cite je me suis
battu pendant deux ans pour lutter
contre cette baisse je n'ai pas du tout
été écouté une baisse de 6 % sur deux
ans c'était du jamais vu même sur la
droite
fin de citation même si la remarque du
premier ministre peuvent apparaître
désobligeantes à l'égard de son
prédécesseur à matignon
il n'empêche que les réductions
drastiques que du budget culturelles
conjugués aux réductions des dotations
de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales rendent à l'équation
budgétaire culturel totalement insoluble
pour les élus locaux que nous sommes
forcés de constater sur le terrain que
l'austérité est de rigueur dans le
domaine culturel et que c'est la
signature de décéder festival adossé
désormais aux seules subventions
municipales
prenons l'exemple de mon département où
olivier py directeur du festival
d'avignon festival qui va débuter samedi
vient de raccourcir de deux jours la
durée du festival
car la subvention municipale a été
réduite de cinq cent mille euros par le
maire socialiste d'avignon qui je le
reconnais ne pouvait pas faire autrement
vous le savez madame le ministre 2000
festival sont organisés chaque année en
france et malgré l'appel que vous avez
récemment lancé aux collectivités
locales qui se trouve face à des choix
budgétaires très difficile vous ne
pouvez pas exiger qu'elles stabiliser
leur financement culturel
les élus locaux sont en effet dans
l'obligation de posséder
eu égard au contexte financier contraint
un tour de vis sur les subventions
accordées aux associations à caractère
culturel et en particulier sur les
festivals de nos départements
alors madame la ministre à l'heure où
plus que jamais je dis bien plus que
jamais notre pays un besoin évident de
culture
que comptez vous entreprendre pour
sauver ces festivals de province qui
soit théâtre de théâtre musical qui
jusqu'à ce jour trouvé la majorité de
leurs financements
environ 70 % auprès des collectivités
territoriales merci de me répondre la
parole était à fleur pellerin
maëlys de la culture vous avez la parole
si monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur merci pour cette question qui
effectivement préoccupe tout comme vous
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs je voudrais apporter un
certain nombre de précisions d'abord je
ne reviendrai pas sur le passé je ne
commenterai pas le bilan de ma
prédécesseure puisque ce serait
discourtois
mais est-ce que je tiens à dire
néanmoins c'est que s'agissant des
festivals vous le savez très bien et
vous avez rappelé vous même les chiffres
il y a plutôt entre 2000 et 3000
festivals en france l'état le ministère
de la culture n'en soutien des
partenaires financiers que d'une
centaine d'entre eux une dizaine de très
grands festivals à rayonnement
international sur ces 100 festival
l'engagement financier de l'état n'a pas
varié au cours des deux dernières années
au cours des trois dernières années
donc l'état le ministère de la culture
ce gouvernement n'a pas sacrifié sa
participation au prêt aux côtés des
festivals qui avaient pour tradition
d'accompagner donc vous l'avez dit c'est
un choix politique c'est un choix
politique le choix de la culture est un
choix politique ce gouvernement qui
réalise 50 milliards d'économies a fait
le choix budgétaires de maintenir et
même d'augmenter le budget du ministère
de la culture
donc je répond également à votre
question vous me demandez que comptez
vous faire
et bien déjà moi je considère qu'un
budget monsieur le sénateur un budget
c'est toujours décret dire au service
d'un projet donc je ne suis pas dans une
logique incrémentale où je demande
toujours plus d'argent pour avoir plus
d'argent
je souhaite proposer un certain nombre
de projets et j'ai des priorités qui
sont le soutien à la jeune création et
la transmission des savoirs l'éducation
artistique et culturelle et c'est pour
financer ses projets que je me bats
auprès du premier ministre ou auprès de
mon collègue secrétaire d'état en charge
du budget dans les discussions que nous
avons actuellement pour défendre nos
budgets pour défendre le budget du
ministère de la culture
vous savez bien qu'en ce moment au lieu
les discussions budgétaires
c'est pour moi important de défendre un
projet et ensuite de défendre un budget
qui soit au service de ce projet est
donc le gouvernement a fait le choix
politique de maintenir le budget de la
culture alors que par ailleurs nous
réalisons beaucoup de d'économies pour
pouvoir être responsable budgétairement
et réduire le déficit public de notre
pays ce que nous avons fait depuis deux
ans alors que vous même ne l'avait pas
fait donc sur les festivals moi ce que
je souhaiterais vous dire c'est que j'ai
confié une mission à pierre cohen pour
pouvoir objectiver la situation parce
que vous conseillez vous dites que les
festivals ont été annulés mois je
souhaiterais vous dire que c'est l'avis
des festivals également parfois de
disparaître parfois d'être créée il ya
de nouveau qx56 aux coupures qui ont été
créées l'année dernière donc il faut
objectiver la situation et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé à
pierre cohen de médée est d'aider les
élus aussi à comprendre la raison
les raisons qui font que des festivals
sont aujourd'hui en difficulté
je ne manquerai pas de vous en tenir
informés merci